Speaker 1: We have a very interesting new
development in the brew now. Hypothetical
2024 Republican presidential matchup. Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump are essentially even right now in
terms of the betting odds for 2024. Now, I want
to remind everybody this this is not polling,
okay? This is you go to predict it, dawg, and you
can bet on who you believe will be the nominee.
For the last many, many months, Donald Trump has
been the clear. But increasingly by a smaller
margin favorite in terms of the betting
odds to be the 2024 Republican nominee.
Over the last two days after the FBI served a
search warrant at Trump's home, Ron DeSantis
actually pulled ahead and then as of moments ago
in a virtual tie. Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis
for 2024. In terms of not who will you vote
for, but who will you bet on being the nominee
right now? In order to win a dollar, you have to
bet $0.37 on Donald Trump being the nominee. And
in order to win a dollar, you have to bet $0.36
on DeSantis being the nominee. It is a virtual tie
and every reason to believe that this change is
tied to the search warrant and the increasing
legal problems for Trump. Trump pleading
the fifth more than 400 times yesterday,
which I will talk about in the next segment. In
terms of polling, how does the polling actually
look? It still favors Trump very clearly. New
polls. We have a Yahoo! News poll, YouGov, the
Yahoo! News poll from late July, early August
that has Trump plus nine. And then before that,
at the end of July, a Harris Harvard poll that has
Trump plus like 30. Okay. So it is tightening. But
also Donald Trump is still clearly the favorite
among current Republican voters. We are going
to be watching these numbers very closely. I
don't want to spend a lot of time on it today,
but we are certainly going to be keeping an eye on
it. The numbers are tightening. And remember that
DeSantis hasn't announced anything. Trump hasn't
either. But Trump has been all but announcing,
saying things like, we might have to do it again.
I think you're going to be very happy with what we
decide, etc., etc. It is not clear that Trump
would necessarily win a contested Republican
primary, which would be an extraordinary thing
for a one term president who lost an unprecedented
situation could be facing us in 2024, but we
have 2022 coming up first. And so that's where
our focus will be. Let me know your thoughts
on where you see this Republican primary going.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We will talk
about pleading the fifth after this short break.